ich stehe hier vor einem Wirtshaus oder
wie man hier sagen würde words Haus denn
ich bin in Los Angeles in Amerika und
hier gibt es ein deutsches Restaurant
welches sich heute einfach mal testen
möchte weil wir haben das gesehen und
wir haben uns gedacht wie schmeckt es
wohl in einem deutschen Restaurant in
den Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika wir
haben ganz wilde Sachen auf der
Speisekarte stehen wir haben gerade
schon alles gegessen und gedreht und ich
kann so viel sagen es lohnt sich das
Ganze anzuschauen weil viele Sachen sind
anders als erwartet wie das Ganze in der
auslandswahrnehmung so ist dreht sich
hier vieles um Bier also wir haben ganz
viele verschiedene Bierkrüge eine
riesige Bar wir haben aber auch einige
fußballelemente also an den Wänden
hängen irgendwelche Fußballtrikots und
man merkt so ein bisschen diesen
Stereotypen Blick auf Deutschland aber
nichtsdestotrotz sind das ja alles
Sachen die in Deutschland auch viel
identität stiften und dementsprechend
schon irgendwo auch ihre
Daseinsberechtigung haben wir haben
diese typischen bayerischen Fähnchen so
weil für viele Amis ist glaube ich
Deutschland auch einfach Bayern oder
Österreich vielleicht sogar aber wie das
Ganze im aussieht das können wir nur
sehen wenn wir reingehen deshalb machen
wir jetzt genau das suchen uns einen
schönen Platz und lassen es uns
hoffentlich gut gehen
[Musik]
hier sitzen wir also wir dürfen schon
mal hier Filmen das ist sehr gut wir
sind die einzigen Gäste bisher der Laden
hat aber auch gerade eben erst
aufgemacht deshalb ist das keine Indiz
dafür dass es schlecht ist was ich schon
mal sehr sehr gut liest ist die Bier
Karte weil es gibt wirklich mehr Bier
Auswahl als eigentlich in jedem
deutschen Restaurant also wir haben Früh
Kölsch was natürlich super ist als
Kölner ich habe auch irgendwo Einhänger
gesehen was ich sehr gerne trinke wenn
ich in den Süden fahre ich sehe auch
klassische Kölsch Preise
8,50€, 50 und ganz klassisch auch bei
Kölsch die zwei Liter
für 32
$ klassisch beim aktuellen Wechselkurs
wahrscheinlich so 33 Euro würde ich
glaube ich genauso bestellen um ehrlich
zu sein wir sind seit fünf Tagen hier in
den Vereinigten Staaten und wir haben
uns glaube ich von drei verschiedenen
Sachen ernährt Burger Fried Chicken
Donuts okay und dann vielleicht noch wir
haben es auf jeden Fall voll ausgekostet
dass wir hier sind und dass wir ja die
volle Vielfalt der amerikanischen Küche
testen können aber jetzt so ein schönes
deutsches Gericht hat auch was
hoffentlich ist auch schön wenn wir uns
die Karte mal so anschauen dann haben
wir einige alte Bekannte und auch andere
Sachen die weniger bekannt sind also
Linsensuppe chicken Nudel zu Caesar
Salad Burrata Salat auf jeden Fall
klassisch Deutsch dann haben wir
Reibekuchen Weißwurst Currywurst haben
wir Trüffel Pommes ja das die Neue
Deutsche Welle der Bürgermeister weiß
die chickenschnitzel Sandwich man merkt
auf jeden Fall dass die Karte ein
bisschen einen Schritt auf die la
amerikanische Community zugemacht hat
aber im Kern gibt es auch viele deutsche
Gerichte und seit 10 Jahren hat der
Laden hier auf deshalb denke ich mal das
wird passen was mir aber genau auswählen
und bestelle von dieser riesigen Karte
weiß ich noch nicht aber ihr werdet bis
jetzt sehen
Currywurst wow
denke ich so much wir haben Käsespätzle
Currywurst und ein Pretzel so wir haben
uns gedacht wir bestellen zwei Sachen
bei denen wir testen können wie nah sie
am deutschen Original sind und eine
Sache die ferner nicht sein könnte vom
deutschen original bzw Schnitzel ist ja
streng genommen österreichisch deshalb
hätten wir auch ein Wiener Schnitt zu
bestellen können die Käsespätzle werden
wir zuallererst einmal begutachten es
sieht aus als würden sie Käse auf jeden
Fall extrem ernst nehmen in einer von
der Seite rein
wir haben dazu noch extra Bacons es
sieht ein bisschen anders aus als man es
vielleicht kennt so super flüssig so ne
wofür habe ich so eine halbe Stunde lang
gepustet gerade eben Alter was ich
geschmeckt habe hat sehr sehr gut
geschmeckt diese Käsesoße ist so nicht
purer Käse so das war die Befürchtung
glaube ich von uns allen als wir gesehen
haben dass das so bündig stand oben am
Pfannenrand darf man so okay da ist
jetzt einfach nur so übelst viel Käse
drin sorry übrigens hast du ein bisschen
laut ist hier aber so ist es halt weil
ich finde es wirklich lecker
also ich muss sagen für meinen Teil die
Cremigkeit ist von Point also cremiger
als ich das häufig in Deutschland
gegessen habe aber schmeckt echt anders
ja so die Konsistenz von dieser Soße ist
einfach anders ne so schaumiger
irgendwie aber sehr lecker hat das was
mit einer authentischen Käsespätzle zu
tun im Ansatz weil außer auch in
Erzählungen jetzt verstehe ich noch
nicht ganz ich finde rechts Zwiebel
fehlen ja auf jeden Fall das so ein
bisschen wie Käsesoße mit Peter mehlsoße
gestreckt ist so ein bisschen also
dadurch wird es einfach so noch mehr
Soße noch flüssiger noch schaumiger noch
cremiger wahrscheinlich auch noch
ungesünder als Käsespätzle eh schon sind
es ist aber ein leckeres geritten auf
jeden Fall also in der Bechamel
Vergleich zu machen es ist lecker
mit Käse einfach untergehoben immer
weiter und ist wenig so soßig wie in
diesem Fall und der Bacon ist ein guter
gutes extra gutes amerikanisches extra
was man in dem Urlaub machen kann dass
man einfach die eigene Landesküche Essen
geht aber für euch und für uns natürlich
sehr sehr interessant also ja es ist auf
jeden Fall ein anderer Tag ist es 100%
authentisch nein werde ich diesen Rucola
Salat probieren nein weil der überhaupt
nichts mit deutschen zu tun haben und
für das Video irrelevant ist aber sehr
relevant für das Video ist diese
Currywurst hier wir haben das muss man
schon sagen ein bisschen sparsam ne die
Soße sieht sehr gut aus also so von der
Konsistenz her sehr sehr nice riecht
auch perfekt Currywurst haben wir auch
ein weiteres Mal schon gesehen in einem
food market wird sie besser sein als
unsere eigene Currywurst Soße das ist
die Frage ich probiere sie ich sag so
unsere eigene die von Frank Rosinen
nachgekochte und point ja also als
Currywurst Soße braucht vielleicht nicht
die beste meines Lebens aber sie
schmeckt richtig gut und die Currywurst
an sich die Wurst hat wenig bis gar
keinen Biss aber die Currysauce ist on
point die Wurst wurde glaube ich einfach
nicht frisch gedreht und reingeschnitten
sondern ist schon so ein bisschen ready
und das wird dann portioniert aufgewärmt
weil eigentlich so die können ja hier
auch gute Wurst Grillen so ne das ist ja
kein Problem einfach keine gute Wurst
Bro ich glaube das war auch Problem was
ich schon so bei Goodbye Deutschland Mal
gesehen habe
was guckst du dir so an in der
Arbeitzeit probieren ich beschreibe euch
Eric Couch gerade die Wurst er guckt
konzentriert der Mund ist leicht offen
beim Kauen der formuliert seine Gedanken
er schmeckt was passiert auf der Zunge
wir werden es gleich erfahren und voll
bei dir also die Wurst schneidet etwas
schlechter ab aber insgesamt dazu Pommes
und Mario Digger das Ding ist wir haben
ja die Currywurst Experte Nummer eins in
Deutschland am Start und zwar Lara
dann kommen wir jetzt auch zum dritten
Gericht zum großen Fragezeichen des
heutigen Tages wir haben einen
pretzelschnitzel also das ist quasi
sowie eine Panko Panade das hier sind
alles klein gemachte brezelstückchen da
drin haben wir ein Schweineschnitzel
hier oben haben wir eine Käse Biersoße
ich weiß schon gar nicht was abgeht
obendrauf Bacon das hier ist der
klassische Kartoffelsalat wir starten
mit dem am wenigsten polarisierenden und
zwar diesen Bratkartoffeln die sehen
anders aus als Brauhaus Bratkartoffeln
die man kennt und ich finde sie sehen
vor allem eher aus wie Ofenkartoffeln
mhm schmeckt aber nice also hat jetzt
nicht so dieses fettige briefende
bratkartoffel-feeling so was man aus dem
deutschen Wirtshäusern kennt schmeckt
aber trotzdem so charakteristisch so
nach Kartoffeln innen drin so dieses
kartoffelbreiartige Sonne ich finde es
halt viel schöner wenn die in Scheiben
geschnitten sind guck mal das Ding ist
hier würde ich in Deutschland sofort
unterstellen so von der Farbe her und so
dass das zum Fertigprodukt ist ne aber
es kann kein Fertigprodukt sein weil es
gibt ja irgendwo deutschen
Kartoffelsalat zu kaufen deshalb nehme
ich mir eine Gabel vom Kartoffelsalat
tut es mir gleich Leute wir probieren
man hätte es überhaupt nicht erwartet
der schmeckt wirklich ganz typisch der
schmeckt bis jetzt am typischsten
überhaupt nicht aber sehr lecker und
hier in diesem Szenario würden Amerika
auch im Geschmack den ich gar nicht
erwartet hätte Schnitzel vs 100 Stunden
Schnitzel Mama mir also wir haben jetzt
natürlich die anderen Sachen erstmal
gegessen weshalb das ganze schon
bisschen trocken ist äh hier sind
wirklich noch so brezelstückchen drin ne
also auch so ganze ich nehme mal ein
bisschen von unserer Käse Soße mit Bacon
also ich glaube das Gehirn wird sagen es
schmeckt sehr gut weil es einfach so
fettig und frittiert und knusprig ist
aber wir probieren wirklich zu schmecken
[Musik]
so der Crunch in der Panade ist so wie
der von so einer Packung Salzstangen die
man so einen Tag lang offen gelassen hat
also der Crunch ist noch da aber dadurch
dass das so frittiert wurde ein bisschen
lag der hat es nicht mehr so diese
krasse Knusprigkeit aber man schmeckt
halt trotzdem voll krass die Salzstadt
es ist so nicht Brezel so weiche frische
gebackene Brezel sondern so Salzstange
so kleine salzbrezelteil eigentlich
lecker ich finde es auch lecker aber es
hat natürlich überhaupt nichts mit
deutscher Küche zu tun ne
es ist nicht schlecht aber auch nicht
wirklich gut ne also jedes normales ist
besser deswegen verstehe ich nicht warum
man das macht ich glaube das ist einfach
so weil die Amis so auf pretzes abfahren
es gibt ja auch dieses Wechsels pretzels
und sowas ne irgendwie ist das so ein
Ding hier so ein verkaufsring ne ich
glaube auch
und dann verkaufen die das eher als
normales Schnitzel jedes geile knusprige
schönen dünnen geklopft Wiener Schnitzel
ist einfach besser als das und hat
wahrscheinlich die Hälfte der Kalorien
deshalb das ist auf jeden Fall ein
dickes l für mich aber wir wollten es ja
testen und trotzdem haben wir die
Erfahrung gemacht wir wollten es testen
nicht zuletzt um vielleicht eines
Besseren belehrt zu werden aber in dem
Fall haben wir das in Europa sagen nicht
Deutschland das Österreich ein bisschen
besser drauf würde ich sagen die
Erfahrung war trotzdem super interessant
also aber zum Abschluss haben wir noch
eine ganz besondere Sache bei der ich
eigentlich auch denke dass sie gut sein
wird ein Apfelstrudel der kommt jetzt
gleich den testen wir und der beendet
das Video ein wunderbarer schön warmer
Apfelstrudel
Vanilleeis und Roadtrip say aber diese
sieht irgendwie nicht so gut aus also
das ist das einzige was direkt auffällt
schon mal das wird der Apfelstrudel
sieht so richtig schön kompakt aus ist
wie gesagt wunderbar schön warm und ich
glaube er wird auch knusprig sein können
wir mal hin bei der lauten Atmosphäre
also ein bisschen auf jeden Fall ich
mache jetzt so wie ich normal essen
würde ich nehme so ein bisschen von dem
Vanilleeis und der Roten Grütze machen
wir so einen fetten riesenlöffel fertig
den ich jetzt probiere
ganz normal ne komplett geil sogar ja
besser als der Apfelstrudel den ich auf
vielen skierten gegessen habe auf jeden
Fall geil richtig geil schön warm sehr
sehr süß natürlich Sweets können Sie
hier ne es ist übrigens auch eine
Vanille Sahne
oh diese obere Schicht vom Apfelstrudel
richtig richtig geil knusprig alles also
rund um alles auch wenn es wieder
vielleicht ein bisschen anders aussieht
als man es kennt so sieht wieder sehr
sehr krass aus Vanillesoße gab es leider
nicht dafür Vanilleeis das ist
wahrscheinlich gemeinsam mit dem
Käsespätzle das leckerste was wir heute
hatten wenn ich mir das alles noch mal
vor Augen führe würde ich den
Käsespätzle ich drehe jetzt einfach nur
vom Geschmack nicht wie Nase ans
Original reingekommen ist den
Käsespätzle würde ich so einhalb von 10
geben weil das irgendwie auf eine Art
und Weise richtig war dass sie so ein
bisschen Richtung Mac and Chees ging
Currywurst siebeneinhalb das Schnitzel
kann nur ganze Sprünge machen
sechseinhalb und das hier der neuen ich
finde das schmeckt richtig richtig geil
schön dass das hier gibt schön dass auch
eine Interesse besteht an der deutschen
Küche ich freue mich jetzt darauf die
nächsten Tage wieder nichts anderes als
Tacos Burger und chicken Sandwiches in
mich reinzuhauen das war eine nette
Abwechslung wir sehen uns zum nächsten
Video wieder und keine Sorge es gibt
noch weitere Videos aus Amerika in den
ich auch andere Sachen esse als
deutsches Essen viel Spaß dabei hier ist
ein für dich vorgeschlagenes Video das
kannst du dir liebend gerne anschauen
bis zum nächsten Mal das gerne aber da
ciao ciao und ciao